let's now generalize what we did in the
last video so if this is my
y-axis
and this is
that's not that straight
this right over here is my
x-axis
and let's say i have two functions so
i'm just going to say in general terms
so let's have a function right over here
so let's say it looks something like
this
so that's one function so this is y is
equal to f of x
and then i have another function that y
is equal to g of x so let's say it looks
something like this
so y
the blue one right over here is
y is equal to g of x and like we did in
the last video i want to think about the
volume of the solid of revolution we
will get if we essentially rotate the
area
between these two and if we were to
rotate it around the x-axis
so we're saying in very general terms
this could be anything but in the way
we've drawn it now it would literally be
that same truffle shape it'd be a very
similar truffle shape where on the
outside it looks like a truffle on the
outside it looks like something like a
truffle and on the inside we have carved
out a cone
obviously this visualization is very
specific to the way i've drawn these
functions but what we want to do is
generalize at least the mathematics of
it
so how do we find a volume
well we could think of disks but instead
of thinking of disk we're going to think
about washers now which is essentially
the exact same thing we did in the last
video mathematically but it's a slightly
different way of conceptualizing it
so imagine
imagine
a
imagine taking a little chunk between
these two
between these two functions
just like that what is going to be what
is going to be the width of this chunk
well it's going to be equal to
dx and let's rotate that whole thing
around the x-axis so if we rotate this
thing around the x-axis we end up with a
washer that's why we're going to call
this the washer method
it's really just kind of the disc method
where you're where you're gutting out
the inside of a disc
so that's the inside of our washer and
then this is the outside of our washer
outside of our washer looks something
like
look something
like that hopefully that makes that
makes sense and so the surface of our
washer
the surface of our washer looks
something like that i know i could have
drawn this a little bit better
but hopefully it serves the purpose so
that we understand it so the surface of
our washer looks something like that and
it has depth of dx
it has depth
dx so let me see how well i can draw
this so depth dx that's the side of this
washer
so a washer you can imagine is kind of a
gutted out it's a gutted out coin
it's a gutted out coin so how do we find
the volume well once again if we know
the surface if we know the area of the
face of this washer we can just multiply
that times the depth so it's going to be
the area of the face of the washer
so the area of the face of the washer
well it could be the area if you had if
it wasn't to gut it out and what would
that area be well it would be pi
times the overall the outside radius
squared it would be pi times the outside
radius squared well what's the outside
radius the radius that goes to the
outside of the washer well that's f of x
so it's going to be f of x is the radius
and we're just going to square that so
that would give us this expression right
over here would give us the area of the
entire face if it wasn't a washer if it
was a coin but now we have to subtract
out the inside
so what's the area of the inside
what's the area of the inside this part
right over here
well we're going to subtract it out it's
going to be pi
times the radius of the inside squared
the radius of the inside squared well
what's the radius of the inside squared
well the inside in this case is g of x
it's going to be pi times g of x
squared that's the inner function at
least over the interval that we care
about so the area of this washer we
could just leave it like this or we
could factor out a pi we could say it's
equal to the area is equal to if we
factor out a pi pi times
f of x squared
minus
g of x squared minus i don't
have to write a parenthesis there so we
can write f of x squared
minus
g of x squared and then if we want the
volume let me put that in the same
yellow if we want the volume of this
thing we just multiply it times the
depth of each of those washers so the
volume of each of these washers are
going to be pi
times
pi times
f of x
f of x squared
minus g of x squared the outer function
squared over our interval minus our
inner function squared over the interval
and then times our depth
times our depth that'd be the volume of
each of these washers now for e and
that's going to be defined at a given x
in our interval but for each exit at
this interval we can define a new washer
so there could be a washer out here and
a washer out here so we're going to take
the sum of all of those washers and take
the limit as we have smaller and smaller
depths and we have an infinite number of
infinitely thin washers so we're going
to take the integral over our interval
from
where these two things intersect the
interval that we care about it doesn't
have to be where they intersect but in
this case that's what we'll do so let's
say x equals a to x equals b although it
could have been from this could have
been a that could have been b but this
is our interval we're saying in general
terms from a
to b
and this will give our volume this right
over here is the volume of each washer
and then we're summing up all of the
washers and taking the limit as we have
an infinite number of them
so let's see if we apply this to the
example in the last video whether we get
the exact same answer well in the last
video y equals g of x was equal to x and
y is equal to f of x was equal to the
square root of x so let's evaluate that
given what we just were able to derive
so our volume i'll do it up here the
volume is going to be the integral what
are the two intersection points well
over here once again we could have
defined the interval someplace else like
between there and there we would have
gotten a different shape but the points
that we care about the way we visualize
it is between x is equal to zero
x is equal to zero and x is equal to 1.
that's where these two things intersect
we saw that in the last video
of
pi
times what's f of x squared f of x
squared square root of x squared is just
x
minus g of x squared
g of x is x that squared is x squared
and then we multiply times dx
so this is going to be equal to we can
factor out the pi
0 to 1 x minus x squared
dx which is equal to pi times
let's see the anti-derivative of x is x
squared over 2. anti-derivative of x
squared is x squared over three
x sorry x to the third over three and
we're going to evaluate this from zero
to one
so this is going to be equal to i'm
running out of my real estate a little
bit let me let me scroll over to the
right a little bit so this is going to
be equal to
pi
times well if when you evaluate this
whole thing at one you get see you get
one half minus one third one half minus
one third
and then you subtract it evaluated at
zero but that's just going to be zero
zero squared over two minus zero third
over zero to the third power over three
that's just all going to be zero so when
you subtract out zero you're just left
with this expression right over here
what's one half minus one-third well
that's one-sixth
this is
one-sixth and so we are left with this
is equal to pi over six which is the
exact same thing that we got in the last
video and that's because we did the
exact same thing that we did in the last
video we just conceptualized it a little
bit differently we generalized it in
terms of f of x and g of x and we
essentially conceptualized it as
we conceptualized it as a
washer as opposed to kind of doing the
disk method for an outer shape and an
inner shape like we did in the last
video